it's the kind of grief that makes your
body buckle
where you struggle to breathe
where life just stops
[Music]
to the parents of
they've come to this Temple to bring
their children's bodies home
it is despair everywhere you look
rasamy srinan Buri has just lost her son
prep and corn was four years old
his mother says he was Lively caring and
always told her how much he loved her
he was sleeping when the attacker
stabbed him in the face
it was so severe I saw the photo of his
dead body I'm totally devastated she
told me I knew the killer since
childhood he was always very good at
school
but he forced his way into her son's
Haven and made it everyone's hell
a bullet hole only a small hint of the
horror inside
here the bottles of milk they never
finished
Marissa is exhausted carrying one baby
as she Mourns another
her four-year-old son was also killed
has lost his wife she was a teacher and
she too was pregnant
he told me it was going to be their
first child his wife was in charge of
the room where the children slept
[Music]
on the sidelines siblings
friends
young minds exposed to the aftermath of
mass murder
police say the 34 year old attacker
panya kamrap was a former police officer
fired from his job in June for drug use
less than 10 minutes drive away we find
where his Rampage ended
his final Act was to come home here he
set fire to his truck walked inside and
murdered his wife and son before taking
his own life
yet more traces of Innocence Lost
another childhood Frozen in Time
across the road Pratt and pawn is also
grieving her 63 year old father udon
knew the attacker but that didn't help
him your father hoped that he'd spare
him my father asked how he was but his
neighbor just shot him she tells me I
can't understand why this happened the
guy was very well educated and my father
was kind to everyone
everything
changed her here no parent wants to
outlive their child
this is a whole Community facing that
very burden it's a heavy heavy weight to
carry
Thailand